so lots of issues this morning to talk
about with the Labor's Shadow trade
secretary Nick Thomas Simmons who joins
me now live Nick Thomason it's very good
morning to you thanks so much for
joining us first of all big win for
labor in Chester what does this say do
you think about your chances of winning
the next election
well firstly very good to be joining you
this morning and the results in Chester
is a landslide result it's a resounding
result that points to a majority labor
government but we are not in any sense
complacent we know the job there is to
do to continue winning the trust of the
British people that is what we are going
to continue to do right up to the day of
the next general election but huge
congratulations to Samantha Dixon our
excellent candidate up there in Chester
uh and huge thanks to all the team on
the ground Who deliver that important
result and it is as well a real message
to the Prime Minister and to the
conservatives that at the moment they
are in government on Morrow time
and you managed a 13.8 swing in Chester
that the national polls are showing
leads for labor that are synonymous with
a swing of 17 do you have a sense of
slight disappointment that you didn't
match up to those National polls
no we we don't have that disappointment
at all because it is very much in the
range it's always a range you can't
predict these things very very precisely
and the range here that we see is that
we are
39 percentage points ahead of the
conservatives in Chester this was a seat
the conservatives uh actually uh won
back from us in 2010 held it up to 2015
when it was one of the most marginal
seats in the country I think the
majority there was 93 votes we've now
won it with the largest Victory we've
ever had in this constituency and indeed
if you're looking at historical
comparators it's a bigger percentage of
the vote than we won Even in our
Landslide year of 1997. so this is a
really resounding result but at the same
time we know there's that work to do
before the next general election
the reason for the by-election in
Chester of course was because of sexual
misconduct by one of your own MPS does
that take the celebrations at all
well of course we we think of the uh the
the victim in that uh particular case
and the very sad reasons uh in which the
by-election uh was caused uh was caused
was of course within the uh Forefront of
our minds and it is a reminder that in
terms of the culture that exists at
Westminster there is still a great uh
deal of work to do there is now the
independent complaints and grievance
process that exists and in what happened
in this particular case here there was
that process that took place and it had
the outcome that it did but it's a
reminder to all of us in politics of our
responsibility that there is still much
to do in terms of changing that culture
let's talk about the prospect of strikes
in the weeks ahead we know that winter
is when the NHS comes under the most
pressure are you worried about the
damage that rumored coordinated strikes
could do to Health Service and patients
when there's already a lot of pressure
there
well strikes do cause disruption they
cause disruption to those who want to
use services and Strikes cause huge
disruption to the lives of those who go
on strike my my own family has been
affected by this my father was on strike
for 13 weeks in the steel strike many
years ago so that's why governments have
to do all they possibly can strain every
sinew to either prevent strikes taking
place in the first place or where there
is an ongoing dispute to do everything
they can to find a compromise and this
conservative government has either been
doing nothing and standing on the
sidelines pretending it's nothing to do
with them or they've been aggravating
situations and making them worse by
threatening legislation on restricting
the right to strike it's time ministers
actually did their jobs on behalf of the
public and did everything they can to
get people around the table and resolve
these disputes but there will be a lot
of people who are really worried about
the care they might get in hospitals
this winter because of strikes should
unions hold off strike action until a
time when the NHS is under less pressure
than it is right now
I think both both the unions and the
government will need to continue uh
dialogue as much as they possibly can
both in respect of trying to avoid the
strikes if possible and to minimize the
disruption that takes place that and and
I have to say that is what uh in in
respect of the health care sector that's
what Unison have been trying to do it's
been the secretaries of State for health
that haven't been engaging around the
negotiating table that's where the fault
lies for not actually seeking to find a
resolution to these matters but there's
still time it's often the case that you
can get a deal in these things at the
11th hour and that's what ministers
should be trying to do now